[Music]
you are the cargo director on the maiden
voyage of the SS buoyant and you've
agreed to transport several tanks
containing the last specimens of a
critically endangered fish species to
their new aquarium unfortunately as
you're passing through shark-infested
waters the boat is battered by a fierce
storm throwing your precious cargo
overboard and to make matters worse no
one seems certain just how many fish
tanks are missing fortunately you have a
rescue sub at your disposal but only
enough fuel for one trip to the ocean
floor you need to know where the tanks
are so you can gather them all in one
quick pass not a single fish can be lost
you decide to scan the three sectors of
the ocean floor where the cargo could
have landed thermal imaging shows 50
organisms in the area and you quickly
realize that that number includes both
your fish and some ravenous sharks you
flip on the sonar to get a better look
the image for sector alpha shows four
tanks and two sharks
the image for sector beta shows two
tanks and four sharks and the image for
sector gamma is blank
your sonar has malfunctioned and you're
going to have to go with the info you
have
you check the shipping notes but all you
learn is that each tank had the same
number of fish inside the cargo hold had
space for anywhere from 1 to 13 total
tanks
and finally the old captain tells you
that this area has the odd property that
no two sectors can have the same number
of sharks but every sector will have at
least one and no more than seven there's
no time to waste
the tanks won't withstand the pressure
much longer
as you descend in the sub you review
everything you know how many fish tanks
do you need to find in Sector gamma
hurry the fate of an entire species
depends on you
at first it seems like there are just
too many missing pieces of information
after all you don't know how many fish
or how many tanks there are let alone
how many fish are in each one but then
you remember the best way to compare
multiple pieces of partial information a
table since we know there are 13 tanks
at most and we already see 6 tags in
sectors alpha and beta we know the total
number of tanks must be between 6 and 13
we also know that each sector has a
different amount of sharks with no more
than 7 in each one since there are two
in Sector alpha and four in sector beta
sector gamma can have one three five six
or seven sharks what about the number of
endangered fish out of the 50 total
organisms in all three sectors we know
at least seven are sharks leaving a
maximum of 43 fish inside all the tanks
and the more sharks we find in Sector 3
the fewer fish there are to save now
remember that the fish are equally
distributed across all the tanks why is
that important
because it means that one of the
possible values for the total amount of
fish must be divisible by one of the
tanks and looking at the table we can
see that the only combination that works
is 39 fish divided between 13 tanks with
3 fish in each with sharks swarming
around you quickly pilot the sub through
the first two sectors before retrieving
the remaining 7 tanks in Sector gamma
you've saved the species and taken an
impromptu dive all in all not a bad day
unless you happen to be a hungry shark
[Music]
you